- Today on "Drew",
secrets will be revealed.
It's the most memorable
moments from season one.
- You have changed my life.
(audience cheers)
- I had so much that I wanted
to talk to Oprah about.
I actually didn't sleep the night before.
It all starts now.
(bright upbeat music)
- [Presenter] Please
welcome Drew Barrymore.
- Hello.
Hi, everyone.
The countdown is on for season two
of "The Drew Barrymore Show."
It all kicks off at exactly one week,
Monday, September 13th, and
you're not gonna wanna miss it.
We've got huge guests,
unbelievable surprises,
and a live studio audience.
I can't wait to see your
beautiful faces here in person.
Who knows, you might be on camera.
Until then, let's take a look back
at our favorite moments from season one,
with some inside scoop from yours truly,
a little Barrymore behind
the scenes if you will.
First up, one of the most
impactful moments for me
was interviewing my interview icon.
She is daytime royalty.
Truly.
No one comes close, and I can only hope
to honor her by doing my best.
Here's my chat with the
indomitable Oprah Winfrey.
Welcome to the show.
Dare I say, maybe you've seen it.
- Yes, I have.
And may I say, dare I say,
seeing it actually changed my life.
You have changed my life.
You certainly changed my work life
because I was there for
that very first show
where you beamed in Cameron,
and there you all were.
And we didn't know that you
all weren't in the same space.
I watched that and I said,
"Hey, why can't we do what Drew did?"
And since then,
"Why can't we do what Drew did?"
And since that time, for
"Oprah Conversations"
for Apple TV, the first time I did it
was with President Barack Obama
talking about his book "Promised Land."
And there we were sitting
right across from each other
in my living room in
front of the fireplace.
And I said then, "This
is because of you Drew."
So, thank you, pioneer woman.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
- I have to thank you so
much because you didn't need
to give us the credit, but you did.
And for those who are not aware,
here's a little taped
piece on the technology
of which Oprah and I are talking about.
(upbeat music)
When we launched this show
in the middle of a pandemic,
we had to get creative.
With the magic of technology,
we came up with a way
to transport our guests
from our LA studio right here to New York.
How cool is that?
We knew one person who thought so too.
It's Oprah!
Oprah approved!
Oprah like-y.
Yes, the Oprah was inspired to use
a similar green screen technology
to interview guests like
Chip and Joanna Gaines,
and of course, President Barack Obama.
- Can she see me yet?
- I can.
- This is pretty cool
technology you got here.
- [Drew] Oh, why, thank
you, Mr. President.
And thank you, Oprah.
Listen, we may not be able
to be in the same room,
but we can sure feel
like it and look like it.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
I thank you so much,
because I'm gonna be really honest,
I haven't really admitted this out loud,
but it was really scary
for me to be a girl,
a woman, I don't know what I am,
a female asking for
people to take this risk
and spend this money and ask
ourselves these questions.
And I'm so grateful to my bosses
that they allowed us to do this,
because this was a check
and a risk away from not happening.
And I wanna ask you, is
this where we're going?
The water's out of the bottle.
People are not gonna travel
the way they used to.
People have gotten comfortable
with interview styles,
some are gonna show up, some aren't.
You're gonna have access to more people
than you ever did in some ways,
'cause the technology, it's
all gonna be maybe a mixed bag.
And if it is, don't we
have to make it the best
and most compelling television
in honor of the audience?
Yeah, I, 1000% agree with that.
And I think that's why I say
you literally have changed my life.
And when people say that, I say,
"'Cause, listen, after Drew,
uh-uh, I'm not going nowhere."
(audience laughs)
And so, the truth is you're
able to have better access.
And I think there will certainly be times
in both of our lives,
and in our careers,
when being directly in front of the person
makes a world of difference
and may be necessary.
But I think that in terms of having access
to anybody in the world at any time,
what you all did in that first show,
lit the path for changing it forever.
And I'm sure we would have done it today,
but where there's no studio.
So I'm like in the middle
of nowhere out here,
you need a studio to be able to do it.
- You really do.
- If there was a studio within 500 miles,
I would have done it.
- I'm so glad.
And may we do it again in the future?
Because I was so glad
to see you embracing us,
you acknowledging us and us
moving forward in this way,
because it does become a new normal.
And for the girl who felt really,
honestly, again, this is the part
I don't talk about, is
when you're fighting
for things in business,
it's not comfortable,
especially when they're not done.
You feel like the messy one,
you feel like the one who might be
spending people's money
in an improper way.
You don't know if the
risk is gonna pay off,
but you get into your convictions
and you fight for them.
And so, when I saw you
embracing the technology,
it told that person who
hung up the phone that day,
'cause I remember saying,
"Listen, you guys, we have got to do this.
We have got to find a new way
for our future of television.
This is not funny.
We are in a really unprecedented time
and we can't go on with
the home show forever.
We just can't."
- You did the thing that I had to do
a thousand times over the years.
And when I first started,
so let me applaud you for doing
the thing that every person,
particularly every woman needs
to learn as soon as possible.
Your gut is right for you.
So when you feel something in your gut,
and you think, "Wow, I need
to really move on that."
That means it is right for you.
It doesn't mean that it's
right for everybody else.
And I think it takes
women in particularly,
a long, long time to be
affirmed in their own beliefs.
And that is the reason actually
we were the number one
talk show for 25 years,
is because it always came
back to what do I feel?
What do I feel is my real
intention in doing this?
And I cannot do it if it's not true to me,
even if everybody else says.
And many times, Drew, producers
would come in with ideas,
and I would say, "I can't do that.
I don't know how I can sit in that chair,
and keep a straight face,
and do that, and do that.
I'm not gonna be able to do that."
So, I applaud you for going with your gut
'cause your gut is always right for you.
- Well, I think you've given
so much courage to everyone,
especially women to fight
for what we believe in.
And I was gonna ask you
if you had any advice,
may I ask when you ended your first season
and you knew you were rounding
the corner into season two,
what were you telling yourself?
- I actually was telling myself,
"Self, you was right,"
because most people don't know this now,
but when we launched in 1986,
I had been a local talk show
in Chicago for two years.
What I understood was
that there's a commonality
in our human experience
and that people are no
different in Chicago
than they are in New York,
than they are in Idaho,
than they are in Rhode Island
when it comes to the core.
Now everybody's so divided
about their politics,
and their beliefs, and so forth.
But I still do believe at the core.
We're all the same.
If you ask blue states,
red states, purple states,
what really matters to you?
The answer is the same.
People care about their families,
they care about being
able to live decent lives,
able to do that in comfort
and do that with a sense of peace.
And I still think in spite
of all the craziness,
in spite of all the divisions,
which is what everybody
talks about all the time,
is that we are more alike
than we are different,
which is a very famous Maya Angelou line.
She used to say that all the time.
And in our humanness,
we are, we all are just
seeking the same things.
And that's what this platform,
"The Drew Barrymore
Show" offers every day,
is a chance for those of
us of like-mindedness,
those of us who are seeking the joy,
who wants to wear some bows.
(all laugh)
- I went extra jaunty for you.
I was like, bows and flowers, it's Oprah.
I'm surprised I don't
have bells on and a boa.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
I had so much that I wanted
to talk to Oprah about.
I actually didn't sleep the night before.
Stay tuned for part two of our chat.
(bright upbeat music)
- What I realized is that
Gayle was my regulation,
makes me wanna cry now thinking about it,
and is still the person in my life.
I have probably three people in my life
who are gonna tell me the
truth, no matter what.
Here's the bottom line,
that really was the
hugest epiphany for me.
(bright upbeat music)
- Welcome back.
Right now, we're diving
into our favorite moments
from season one of "The
Drew Barrymore Show"
with some exclusive host
commentary from me, your host,
and no guest compares
to the queen of daytime,
Miss Oprah Winfrey.
And of course, I had to talk to her
about our mutual BFF, Gayle King,
and all of her favorite things.
But Oprah had a new book out
about how our brains process trauma.
And while I love to talk
about the tough stuff,
and who better to talk about that
than with Oprah Winfrey?
Please take a look at part
two of our conversation.
You now have "Oprah Daily,"
which I happened to mention to Gayle,
that I thought that the "Oprah Daily,"
the daily word, it's so brilliant.
- Well, thank you, thank you.
I actually came up with that
because I wanted it to be...
what I realized is that
"The Oprah Show" was a habit
just like "The Drew Barrymore Show."
People were creating a habit around that.
And that's what you want.
That's your core viewer,
that's who you're speaking to every day.
And the idea of having a
daily inspiration point,
a daily quote, a daily something
that you can rely on to
give you just a little lift.
My whole goal throughout my life,
even before I could articulate it,
is how do you bring a
light into people's lives?
How do you let them see
the best of themselves?
How do you allow them to grow
into becoming more of who they are,
which is what every one of us
is actually aspiring to do,
whether you can articulate
that for yourself or not.
You just wanna become more and more solid.
You wanna have the ability to
have the fullest expression
of yourself as a human being.
And you do that by habits, by rituals,
by creating a space where
you can give back to yourself
in a way that allows you to flourish.
So, we are growing it into what
I know will be in the future
is a daily spot of
inspiration for everybody.
So, thank you for mentioning that.
- We need you on the daily.
I listened to your Sirius XM channel
through both my pregnancies,
and it was my daily north star,
it was my daily fix.
- Well, thank you for that.
- It's true.
I'll never forget the story you told
about Gayle getting the
water for the traffic cop
and how that moment was
her being such an important
and good parent to her son,
because she was showing him
the kind of person to be.
And that gave me hope,
because I felt so lost.
Like, what blueprint do I have to pull on
to become a parent?
I was scared out of my mind.
And I thought hearing that story,
if I can be an example to my kids,
maybe I don't have to draw
from my past or even fight it,
I can try to be myself.
And that can give me
hope to be a good parent.
That story literally changed my life.
So thank you for that.
- Well Gayle is to date,
and she always says,
"Well, all parents do, and all parents."
I said, "No, they don't."
Gayle is to date the best
model parent I have ever seen.
I've never seen anybody who was,
more engaged, more
respectful of her children.
And when she first had kids,
because we were best friends
and met at a television
station in Baltimore,
and once she married
and had kids, I thought,
well, there's gonna be
distance in our relationship
'cause she's not gonna have time
to devote to our friendship,
and that did not happen.
But what did happen every time
she was on the phone with me
and one of her children entered
the room, she would stop,
she would put the phone down.
Even if she couldn't put the phone down,
they would be acknowledged.
She was present there for them.
She would say, "Mommy's on
the phone now with Auntie O"
And, "Morning, Bear."
She calls Kirby Bear.
There was an acknowledgement,
and what I would have
to say over the years,
a mutual respect.
And I know we're gonna be talking later
about the subject of what happened to you.
But one of the things that
Dr. Perry says in this book
is that when children
grow up and they realize
that they are not getting
the respect that they deserve
from their parents, it
changes who they are.
What your kids want,
and this is actually true of everybody,
they wanna know that you're here,
that you see me,
that you see me and you hear
me and that I matter to you.
And that is true for everybody
else in your life, too.
- Speaking of this extraordinary book
that I've been reading,
and I will forever have the chart
that Dr. Perry put in the book as far as-
- The upside down triangle?
- The upside down triangle.
What you guys talk about
as far as the impression
that children are left
with at such an earlier age
than I think was spoken about
in at least my growing up,
I think, even into almost having kids,
I feel like everybody kind of went,
they won't notice when they're young.
And I did not understand
why that was the notion.
It didn't seem right,
it didn't feel right,
but I wanted to believe it
because that's what so
many people had said.
- Here's the bottom line,
that really was the
hugest epiphany for me.
All these years, I've done multiple shows
where people say exactly
what you just said, Drew,
"Oh, they won't remember."
I know, yes, I'm in an
abusive relationship,
and the kids are young,
when they get older, I'm gonna move.
I'm gonna get out of the relationship.
The most damage is done
from zero to two months,
'cause that's the time
when the brain is taking in everything.
And anybody who's ever had children,
you all know this because you get to watch
that whole language socialization process,
how do they learn the word
dada, how do they learn mamma,
how do they learn spoon,
how do they learn?
So, as they're taking in all of that
when the brain is the
most open and receptive,
they're also taking in
all the other stuff.
That changed everything for me,
in terms of how people
are raising their kids
and how we see that what you do
in front of the youngest children matters.
- I have a question, which
is that when I was born,
my dad, he had split with my mom.
And I just didn't know him.
He was very abusive.
He would come around, he
would trash the house.
He was scary.
And there are a lot of people,
and you share a story
of what happened the first night
that you stayed with
your mom in Milwaukee.
And for people who have had a parent,
one or two that did not want to be
in their child's lives for
whatever their reasons were,
which is valid to them,
very hard for a child to understand,
what do you talk through with yourself
or other people who have had that kind of
start to their lives, who
deal with that kind of trauma?
You talk about the eyes
and the being wanted
and the being fed up, right?
What happens when you're not?
- So here's the good
news about all of this,
because all of us have had things
to happen to us in our lives
that caused us to feel unwanted,
and not important.
Everybody has at some point in your life,
even if you come from the
best of circumstances,
it is possible to take
your post-traumatic pain
and turn that into post-traumatic power.
And post-traumatic wisdom.
I know this for sure,
that whatever has happened to you,
can also be for you if you allow it to be.
The thing that has healed me the most
is taking the pain that I endured,
suffered, survived as a child
and turning that inside out.
So that is why I created
my school specifically
looking for girls who were just like me,
who came from poor backgrounds,
who came from dysfunctional backgrounds,
who many times felt unwanted, unloved.
How do I create an environment for them?
How do I give back?
This is how you save yourself.
How do I give back that
which I was not given.
And when you can do that,
you begin to fill the
hole inside yourself.
That giving back has become
really what my legacy is.
And I will share this with you,
that I was sitting with Maya Angelou
after I'd come back from
the opening of my school.
And I said, oh, this
is gonna be the school.
This is gonna be my greatest legacy.
I mean, these girls,
this is what my life was for.
And she said, "You have no
idea what your legacy will be."
And I said, "Oh, no, no, no, no, Maya,
you should have been there.
I'm telling you it's gonna be the school."
And she said, "I said you have no idea
what your legacy will be.
Your legacy is every life you touch.
Your legacy isn't your name on a school
or any other building.
Your legacy is every life you touch."
So I say this to you, Drew Barrymore,
your legacy, this is what Maya said to me,
"Everybody who's ever
watched a show and decided
I'm gonna go back to school.
I'm gonna go on a diet.
I'm gonna treat myself better.
I'm gonna leave an abusive relationship.
Every life that you have touched
that has experienced your voice
and the power of your platform.
That is your legacy."
(audience applauds)
- Guess what, ladies and gentlemen,
we're gonna have a little Oprah
sprinkled throughout our show this season,
as we have partnered with oprahdaily.com,
I am on that feed daily for sure.
For some special news
features in Drew's News,
we'll be in collaboration.
What a dream come true.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back.
Right now I want to talk about
a dear friend who has taught me
so much about food and cooking
over the last three years.
She's also a part of the Drew Crew,
which is an amazing group
of our shows contributors,
alumni if you will.
Let's take a look at the
best of Chef Pilar Valdes.
She's a culinary goddess,
a woman who deserves a
thunderous standing ovation,
my culinary partner in
crime, she's my dear friend,
it's Chef Pilar Valdes.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Today we're making a peppery steak
with an agrodolce sauce.
- Let's do it.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
- So we're gonna start with
this New York strip over here.
For this recipe,
the reason why I love a New York strip
is because it's tender like a filet
and it has the flavor and
fat, just like a ribeye.
So the first thing we're gonna do
is season up the steak
really, really well.
And then you park that for
like an hour and let it sit.
We have some freshly
crushed black pepper corns.
You can lay that on your plate or on top,
and you're gonna press down to adhere.
So we've seasoned off both sides.
And meanwhile, you want your pan heating
over medium to medium high heat.
When your pan is nice and hot,
you're gonna add some oil.
And right here, actually,
we have a steak that has been searing.
So it's nice and hot.
- Time to turn it over?
- Yeah, I like to, oh, look at that.
Beautiful.
(audience cheers)
So this recipe is gonna cook
stove top for six minutes,
but just make sure
you're doing essentially
the same amount of time on both sides.
- [Drew] Same amount
of time on both sides.
- And we're gonna finish
this steak in the oven.
- Okay.
- That's the clue.
One thing to look for when you're going
into the oven is definitely
use an oven thermometer.
So we're gonna make the
agrodolce sauce real quick.
- [Drew] Let's do it.
- We're gonna dump everything in,
that's two tablespoons of shallots,
- Two tablespoons shallots.
- All of that roughly chopped cranberries.
Wonderful food.
And then that is my balsamic over there.
Some water,
and then we're gonna do some honey.
So all you have to do
is basically bring this
to a boil and then simmer it
for four minutes until
it's nice and thick.
And the last little thing is off the heat,
we're gonna pour in our mustard.
So we actually, on the side, Drew,
have a steak, beautiful
steak that has been resting,
critical piece to cooking steak,
rest your meat for at least 10 minutes.
So the last thing to do is just spoon
some of that beautiful sauce on.
- Oh, this cut's, wow,
- I guess you just gotta take a taste.
- I'm sorry.
I don't, I just eat.
It is really, really good.
For today a quinoa risotto
with winter squash,
seared mushrooms and fresh
herbs, shall we jump in?
- Yes, we shall.
- So the first thing you're gonna do
is actually roast your squash.
- And you're gonna roast them
at like 400 for about 20?
- 20 to 30.
What I like to do is
actually cut the squash
into chunks like this,
drizzle some olive oil,
salt, and pepper, stick it in
the oven, 20 to 30, let it go.
And then you're gonna take it out
and we're actually gonna make a puree.
So you're gonna take the chunks
and let's pop that in the blender.
Lovely.
And then you're gonna
have some stock actually.
- [Drew] Oh, the vegetable stock.
- There you go, a little
bit of vegetable stock.
- Here we go.
Yeah, baby.
Lovely.
So in the meanwhile,
we had some of our quinoa going,
what I like to do is
I start toasting it
first in a dry skillet.
It adds this really nice
nuttiness to the dish.
- I have to say, I've
not seen people do that.
- Yeah, it's really lovely.
45 seconds in a hot, dry pan.
- Dry, that's the key.
Don't put oil in it.
- No, no oil, no nothing.
And then you're gonna add
some liquid into that.
We use vegetable stock
and you're gonna bring
that to a boil and then
turn it down to simmer.
And you're gonna mix it
and stir it and cook it
for about 18 minutes.
So we're gonna take our puree.
- You're gonna take your puree,
which I recommend folding in.
- It feels like a hug and a bowl
is what I like to say, which is-
- I want a hug in a bowl, Pilar.
Am I gonna start arranging?
- Yes, please arrange a range away.
- Now, these are trumpet mushrooms.
- They are trumpet mushrooms.
I love mushrooms.
- I'm excited to bring what
should be a really heavy,
heavy dish to this
lightness that is so healthy
and good for your body,
but still gives all of that satisfaction.
And thank you.
- And it's delicious.
- For the satisfaction, baby.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
- I love you.
They taste like peanut butter.
- And with a salt on top, I mean.
- Mm-hm.
- Oh my God.
This is a true original,
just like you, Pilar.
- Thank you.
- I love you.
I couldn't do it alone.
I could only do it with Pilar.
(audience applauds)
I love you, Pilar, so much.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
Even the stars who come on
our show, get star struck.
Here's someone we love talking about
a time they met someone they love.
- The biggest time I was starstruck.
I was invited to an after party
at the Russian Tea Room
to meet Paul McCartney,
talking to Paul McCartney
is just bizarre because he'll be like,
"John used to sit like that."
And you go, "John Lennon.
That's who you're talking about?"
Yeah, 'cause you're Paul McCartney.
And so I just kept like
kind of stuttering,
just staring and kind of blinking a lot.
Ask him all the dumb questions you ask
about the Beatles and Paul McCartney.
I remember I told my mom,
I might be going to this.
My mom's like, "If you go
to the Russian Tea Room,
you have to get a Moscow mule.
The owner comes over and says,
"Can I get you anything?"
And I go, "Can I be a Moscow mule?"
And Paul would be like, "He's cool.
Do you want to reform the
Beatles with you in it?"
He doesn't even hear me.
And the rest is history
and we currently don't speak.
- You know what?
We all freak out over
someone at some point.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back.
When we launched "The
Drew Barrymore Show",
we were in the thick of the pandemic.
And so much was uncertain at the time,
everything including school
teachers, principals,
and parents were stretched so thin.
They were dealing with the impossible.
And on the show, we
talked to many educators
about how they were dealing
with those unprecedented times.
And there was one teacher
whose story really stuck
with me and we were lucky enough
to help him continue to help
all his students at Aiton Elementary.
Take a look at this.
Your story is so incredible.
Like tell us about your
school first of all.
- Yeah.
So Aiton Elementary is a
school in Washington, DC.
It is in ward seven, Northeast DC.
This community has been
underserved for several years.
However, this community is
filled with such cultural wealth.
So I like to describe it as a
culturally wealthy community,
although it is a Title One school
and majority of the students
are receiving free and reduced lunch,
but it is such a loving
and caring community,
down from the parents, to the
teachers, the administration,
everyone in that community really pitches
in to make sure that our
students get what they need.
And it's been a challenge
with the pandemic starting
and teachers really trying to
do everything that they can.
The teachers at our
school have been amazing
to really trying to connect with students,
whether it's through FaceTime
or Twitter, Instagram,
or any sort of way that that
we can connect with students.
That's what we've really been trying.
And it's worked out pretty well for us,
but it is a huge challenge.
- Do you think any of your students
or the other staff members
might be watching right now?
- Maybe, perhaps, we are
closed from school today,
so they could possibly be watching.
I'm not sure.
You know what, I actually know they are,
because they're right here
in our virtual audience.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my God, Harmony, Jaylen, Adrian.
- Thanks you guys so much for hanging out
with us and supporting Alejandro.
So you guys are in virtual learning.
- Yes, yes.
What have you guys been
dealing with going virtual?
- Yeah, I mean, so when the
pandemic first started in March
it was a huge challenge to make sure
that students were still receiving
a high quality education.
And so we really were able to understand
how many students didn't
have access to internet
and students didn't
have access to devices,
and it really was an
eye-opener for a lot of us.
So, we were rushing and copying packets
to try to print as much
work as we can for student teachers,
we're dropping off
supplies at people's homes.
We were doing all types of
things just to make sure
that our students still have
that sense of community that they would
have when they come to
our school building.
So it was a huge challenge and especially
the internet access piece has been huge.
You know, the digital
divide is such a big part
of the conversations
that we're having now.
And we're really seeing how it's affected
students that I teach and
also how it's affected
students around the country.
- Well, we actually reached out to ASUS,
which is a leading tech company,
driven by innovation and quality products
for more than 30 years.
And they're committed
to providing a variety
of education solutions to
connect students and teachers,
and they heard your incredible story
and they are giving us enough
ASUS Chromebooks for every single student
and teacher at Aiton Elementary.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
- That's amazing,
I can't even fathom that.
This is crazy.
Meeting Drew Barrymore,
getting computers for our school.
- [Drew] Computers for the entire school.
- I'm at a loss for words.
- Students and teachers.
- Oh my goodness.
- And all that we want to do on this show
is recognize what's happening around us,
shine a light on people who are being
such extraordinary human beings.
And thank you to ASUS.
We can aid in the technological aspect
that you need as a tool to
be the hero that you are.
- Oh my God, thank you so much.
I can't even, I'm so happy
for everyone at Aiton.
I mean, this community deserves it.
They are just such a strong community
who every single day the students log on
and they have their uniforms on,
they're in front of the computer.
No matter the connection,
no matter if they have a pencil,
no matter anything.
And they just are so
passionate about learning.
So they deserve this so much.
They truly do.
(audience applauds)
- We actually followed up
with Alejandro a few weeks later
to present him with $50,000
and a full scholarship for him
to the National University's
Master's Program.
Gosh, he's so deserves it and more.
By the way,
he also won teacher of
the year in his district.
So I'm just saying, we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back.
Today, we're revisiting our
favorite moments from season
one of "The Drew Barrymore Show",
with a little extra
behind the scenes info,
from yours truly, it's the Barrymore Cut.
Now, my hands down favorite part
of the show every day is Drew's News.
And last season I had
one very special guest
join me at the desk, Gayle King.
Now this segment aired as like
12 minutes total, I think,
but we talked for probably,
I would say for more than almost an hour,
I could've talked to her for another hour.
I love Gayle.
Take a look.
- I get the first headline
they say, so here we go.
Starting with the latest vaccine news,
CBS News reports that
Pfizer has completed a study
and found their vaccine is safe.
And 100% effective for kids.
This is big, ages 12 to 15.
So Pfizer plans to file with the FDA
for emergency use of the
vaccine for kids as young as 12.
I know, Drew, that there's still
some vaccine hesitancy,
but that's changing.
I've heard people say,
well I never got the flu shot.
The difference is if you
didn't get the flu shot,
it only affected you.
If you don't get this vaccine,
it affects all of us and
the people around you.
So I think this is very exciting,
especially for kids because
they can go back to school.
I don't know about Frankie and all,
but aren't they sick of just
looking at a little Zoom, Zoom.
- Everyone has hit a fatigue level.
That's so real.
And we know we're here
for a little longer.
So the sooner we get vaccinated-
- The better it'll be to get back to life.
Have you, I've had mine.
- I've had mine too.
- In all of this difficult roads
that we are all navigating.
I have come to have
a new re-appreciation for entertainment.
- Yup, me too.
- I think when the world falls apart,
you just think entertainment,
bigger picture problems.
And then you're at home for a long time
and you just need an escape.
- It's like entertainment, please.
- Exactly.
So a show like "Bridgerton",
the steamy Netflix hit that broke records
is coming back for season two.
It's been a personal favorite of mine.
Glamor reports that the show plans
to take some real life
inspiration from former royals,
Harry and Megan, and in season two,
the characters Simon and
Daphne, newlyweds, new parents,
will go through some struggles
similar to Megan and Harry.
I think being royals,
having public opinion,
being new parents are sort
of the similar through lines.
Gayle, I can't think of
anyone we've looked to
for the north star other than you
and Oprah for all of the
truths from Harry and Megan.
I think that at interview
opened up conversations
that many people weren't prepared to have,
or didn't want to have.
But I think ultimately it's about a family
that wants to be united and be together.
And I'm hoping that that
that will be the case.
- And have those difficult conversations.
- Yes, yes.
And sometimes conversations
are very difficult.
- Yeah.
I really admire hearing all the details
and opening up that important conversation
and really making history
in a conversation that was refusing
to be had for centuries.
So I'm very happy that the lid is off,
and there's nothing healthy
about not having those
tough conversations.
- There's nothing healthy
when you don't talk.
So let's all wish that for all involved
in that particular story.
- Okay, Gayle, your story up.
- Okay, my turn again.
This is a good one.
A writer at "Cosmopolitan"
recently admitted
that she misses eavesdropping
on awkward first dates.
I love this.
We all miss going out to restaurants.
Yeah, you do with your friends,
you also miss I'll bet,
sitting near strangers and listening
to their private conversation.
Can you relate to this?
Hello, my name is Gayle, yes.
Because haven't you been in a restaurant
and you hear a conversation
between a couple in particular
and it's not going so well,
or you've been on a train
or you're even walking down
the street and you get
a snippet of something,
I've actually turned around
and walk behind the person.
Just so I could hear the end of the story.
Are you one of those people?
- Well, you love Nancy Drew.
- Yes, I do.
- So that's some perfect sleuthing.
- I do.
- I really miss it, it was funny,
Tony Dakota on the show
literally was like, yeah,
you guys should try not dating
apps and meeting in person.
I'm like, have you read
the room the last year?
Nobody's in person.
Of course, but I do think that his point
is important because I think
we will get back to that.
And I tried a dating app for a second.
- You did?
- I did.
Inspired by Bridgerton.
I was like, I gotta put
myself back out there.
- But did you go as Drew Barrymore.
- [Drew] Yes.
- Did you go as your Drew face?
- You have to be honest,
no way to start anything on deception.
I know, but, Drew, I would do it.
I just don't want people
to know that it's me.
- I think also right now
I'm a little confused.
Like, is it my girlfriends I miss,
because for me the truth is,
and I did go on a date
with a guy and he was like,
"You know I".
And I was like, "No, no, no, no, don't."
Listen.
Kids, work, girlfriends, alone
time, fifth is the guy like.
- But when you started to say,
he said you know why, what was he?
- We were both talking about like
why relationships are complicated.
And I was like, I think
I'm really clear about it.
It's sort of my fifth priority.
And I understand-
- That could be a problem.
- Yeah, I guess it is.
- Yeah.
- All right.
Well, today we are tackling
the spring cleaning
on the show and in that spirit,
we must debunk the latest
viral underwear myth.
Videos on TikTok are claiming
that you must replace your underwear every
six to nine months.
- Boo!
- And I'm here to tell you-
- The myth is false.
- Absolutely false.
- Also like how many pairs
of underwear are we talking about?
- Well, I mean, I just think number one,
I have bras that sometimes
you're putting a safety pin.
I know that's bad, I know that's bad.
But I don't understand
why you'd get rid of
it six to nine months.
'Cause it's still in
pretty good condition.
- I think if you have multiple
pairs, you're probably okay.
- Well I have multiple pairs, don't you?
- I do.
- We're not wearing the
same pair of panties.
- And that in that case I would
suggest hygienically disposing of them.
But yeah, women in home asked doctors
and experts and they say,
there is no expiration date on your pants.
- Yes, I believe that.
- So good,
It's not like a toothbrush.
- I believe that.
- They're underpants.
- [Gayle] Look at the
variety that you're showing.
- See, those are pretty.
I feel like I should rock
something more like that.
I feel like-
- Maybe that's why we're single.
We don't want to wear granny panties.
- [Drew] Do you wear granny's?
- No I don't.
- Really?
- Granny panties, no.
I'm not wearing little thongs either,
but no, I'm not wearing granny panties.
- A sensible, sexy panty.
- Does sensible and
sexy go together, Drew?
- Probably not.
(audience applauds)
I'll come back to the Drew's
News Desk as soon as possible.
I love you.
Now, don't go anywhere because up next,
we're gonna let you in on a little secret
about season two of "The
Drew Barrymore Show".
(upbeat music)
♪ If you like fashion ♪
♪ Or easy home decor ♪
♪ New favorite recipes ♪
♪ Plus fun celebrities ♪
♪ Need a little good news ♪
We're back to bring you more.
♪ Barrymore ♪
♪ Drew's all new for season two ♪
♪ Yeah Barrymore ♪
♪ Life improving, stain removing ♪
♪ Barrymore ♪
- [Narrator] The new season of "Drew"
premieres September 13th.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome back.
Season two of "The Drew
Barrymore Show" kicks off Monday,
September 13th, one week from today.
And man, is it gonna be huge, so huge.
In fact, it's bi-coastal,
we're doing shows in New York
and we're doing shows in Los Angeles.
That's right.
I'm going back to my hometown to celebrate
the people and places where I grew up.
It's very personal actually,
and very invitational.
Over the course of the premiere
we're gonna celebrate
your hometowns as well,
because as they say,
there's no place like home
and it's all happening
one week from today,
the season two premiere
of the Emmy-nominated "Drew
Barrymore Show", my goodness.
Make sure to come join us.
Tune in, thanks for watching.
See you soon.
Hopefully.
(upbeat music)
(light music)